hello everybody welcome to the rant cafe
and believe it or not there is major
technical difficulties happening right
now and we cannot hear anough Mac or
maka so hopefully they'll chime in at
one point but for the meantime it's just
the three of us don't want to be late so
we're already late but we don't want to
be too late yeah anyway today we'll be
talking about our top most hyped animate
we're looking forward to 2018 which is
kind of relevant because it's 2018 so
anything you're looking forward to
anybody harami more you have anything in
mind there's just the genre highschool
DxD here bro that's one of the most high
for and of course sao alec ization
there's one when did fully Coolio was
announced was that for 18 or 19 it was
officially announced for 18 but it
wasn't you know talked about for a while
so I'm not holding my breath on that or
on highschool DxD I don't think it is a
date either oh wow yeah the XD does no
confirmation that yes because whenever
whenever there's a new anime that's
announced for a future they always give
it a date like a slot in the next year
like attack on Titan got a slot for 2014
and 2015 and 2016 because they always
just slot it into the year and then if
it doesn't happen they just push it off
oh my gosh she caught you too actually
yes I do I loved it yeah this is pretty
good unfortunately it's short so it's
not going to be a full episodic series
which is saying it's 12 inches it is 12
episodes but it's a short series so it's
gonna be like saga be 24 minutes long
why the first season was no the second
season is a short really yep not
complaining I didn't like the first
season I thought it was too weird
can you guys hear me I like it yeah
it just sounds like death [ __ ] my
quality bro what's up yo so I'm using
the webcam mic now so it's probably [ __ ]
I know but what can we do because my
actual mic is not just with the computer
and what's happening is basically bought
a new computer and we're trying to set
it up now we're building it together
with some friends it's working great so
shout out everything's going according
that point they're helping us build a
computer but we've had to obviously you
know do some setup stuff this is still
the old computer but because we have to
plug some stuff and plug some stuff out
it messed up everything of course you
don't
so that's how we are that's where we are
now but yeah sorry for delay everybody
that's what we've been doing thanks Knox
for taking over you make that one joke
about 2018 I appreciated it so what'd
you guys do a new year with your friends
I knew it I was drinking with friends me
and goes in and watching Netflix stuff
so basically that was it that was it
Netflix the casino saw my money oh yeah
I refuse to go to casinos for that very
reason never again original Knox it
works wait can you hear me no yes we can
oh yeah so by the way I wonder if anyone
will notice
really oh damn mind blood no I could
have just kept it here why do we just
just so you guys know I want to say a
few words first
Nux Taku published part 2 of boruto
abridged be sure to check that out on
his channel link in the description and
I
make an appearance in my first-ever
voice acting gig appearance that left me
very sexually confused
plus it's hilarious and definitely
recommend this noise from you yeah I'm
fortunate cuz I've got this stupid don't
call you baby no come on Mike yeah
watching travellers on TV series all the
first season no yeah no more misses is
this oh you can hear that as almost no I
guess interesting shows the science
makes zero sense but otherwise anyway
just in terms of like we're not gonna
get too much into it but just in terms
of the whole Logan Paul thing guys Logan
Paul okay Paul think I need to briefly
soul we're not gonna get into a
discussion I was gonna say my piece and
then we're gonna see what he did
completely unacceptable and the reason
anyone would even do something like that
I feel is that basically at this
mentality nowadays with youtubers
especially it doesn't matter if
something is right or wrong it's all
what if it gets being and his mentality
is yo if it's gonna get views I'm gonna
do it doesn't matter if it's wrong as a
matter it's right and unfortunately
that's the situation that we got in with
that whole thing in terms of the whole
you know seriousness or mental health oh
my god I can't pretend to know everyone
you know what everyone's going through I
can only speak to my own personal
experience I'm not an expert but I do
think that noble lost paws made a really
good point in his video and he said you
know nowadays a lot of people feel alone
you know in the real world maybe or your
parents you don't get along with your
parents there's no one you can talk to
but at least we have the internet and
communities such as anime fans right
where we can be there for each other and
support each other even if it our
personal lives sometimes it seems like
there's no one there for us so I just
want to say that
this community that we have Red Cafe and
Edmond and all of that means a lot to me
when I was struggling after couldn't
find a job and stuff this did a lot for
me I met some really amazing people
whether you have nice comments they
leave on the videos whether you just
troll meme I love you guys you're a big
part of my life and I hold that together
you know we can make this community make
everyone feel welcome and make sure that
everyone knows that you're not alone
even if it seems like that sometimes am
i right yeah yeah there's a million
things all of us want to say but no one
really wants to hear so could we get to
anime please every youtuber with like
you know every youtuber made a reaction
to this to give my honest opinion for
this community this is no reaction it's
not in the title it something the
thumbnail relax that's everyone's kind
of hurted a little at this point I mean
something knots I appreciate it
I support I support anywhere most
definitely because you know you can go
ahead and talk about which anime you're
looking forward to oh me all of a sudden
okay no not you yes yes I'll take none
oh then I guess I'll take it off well I
already said so that I'm mostly excited
for a dxd hero and Sao season 3 oh
that's exciting
no so what is exciting at least for me
because those are those two of them are
my most favorite shows hmm that might be
a good year for you then yep definitely
gonna be a good year this is gonna be
the party room this is gonna be the
harem here we know there's a lot of and
especially with sequels there's a lot of
hype dub sequels coming up right so we
know obviously attack on Titan I'm so
excited for that seven deadly sins
starting on Saturday guys there we are
my hero academia we have I've so many so
many career sakura yeah kargh after
soccer fairy tale you know it recon
stops
No right so there's a lot of sequels but
the question is then are all of these
gonna live up to the hype or are we
gonna be able disappointed a lot this
year I want to get your take on that
someone's palmistry this here we'll get
dissapointed by at least a handful of
things because as anime evolves and
progresses I don't know there's not this
game to find new fetishes and it's
really scary I don't know um last year
with the little sister lolly bestiality
you know every single fetish ever in one
package it can only get better
last season was that's a lot of lolly
series I don't know how last season was
just full of wall-e series I don't know
why and all long as you take a number
man and the bestiality stuff that was
really big - well I have to agree with
Knox in terms of the whole I guess what
will you call tropes or whatever
fetishes that yeah there's like the
trope of the year whether it's you know
the little sister or whatever and it
just keeps going to the point and I'm
really getting to dislike these animate
that just pander to these whether it's a
current trend or whether it's an
established thing just pandering to this
type of audience that's like oh this is
the next interesting thing now let's
talk about reverse trap military girls
whatever whatever it is whatever it is
German break and bondage military girls
and base basically like I don't
appreciate that recently they take anime
and they're like okay so this is gonna
be half plot half fetish it's just
it's what it sells but it sells that's
the issue well nothing we could do about
that
in any case something I'm really excited
for that only popped up on my anime list
recently to my knowledge is that in the
spring persona 5 is getting an anime oh
so that's really cool getting more and
more news about these animes crazy it
depends you is doing it though who's
who's doing the personify the anime what
pictures I think yeah either really good
or abysmal because when they actually
adapted properly it's like I'm ok with
it but they so often just decide to
change endings and scenes and basically
every anime that I hate the filler arcs
and just going off topic at the end is
that thank you as that's thank you
anyone pictures blue exorcist first
season to let the end was terrible
Valkyria chronicles they change the end
erase t2 change the end I mean as far as
changing can and they're like the
Masters so that's very scary to me
change didn't change the volcano
chronicles they didn't no one changed
nor they did in the last episode she
developed every power ever and destroyed
everyone no in the last episode in the
last couple of episodes in that lot in
that battle leading up to the last
episode yeah
persona that's a video game right so
this is gonna be a video game that's
turned into an anime about clinical this
is a video game that's plot heavy like
the point of this game is the story as
opposed to the game mechanics or social
features or whatever for the most part
the games that you see adapted are let's
say online games that they try their
best and usually fail completely because
there's no story so they have to sort of
come up with their own things in the
games world and that usually fails
that's the ufotable thing right now yeah
from playing persona of course let
you're like me I haven't finished the
game but
there were also cutscenes within that
within the game did a one pictures make
those cutscenes or did no no the game
company made them game company well so I
don't I don't think they're gonna
include those cutscenes than in the
anime I don't know
well I'm sure they'll tweet them I mean
yeah they might tweak it I think if you
can I don't know might make it better
let's just hope anyone pictures you know
god this because we know they failed a
lot of series yeah like so do the best
expect the worst that's what I always
say I was disappointed apocryphal but I
hope they don't do the same to persona
just to address chat for a second
relentless asked whether we think that
this year just kind of on first
impressions of what we know is coming
looks better than last year I would say
yes
just because this year we're going into
the year with a lot of stuff confirmed
so we have a target on season 3
confirmed boku no hero academia season 3
confirmed we have seven deadly sins
confirmed whereas going into last year I
remember we had we didn't always happen
with seven deadly sins we didn't know if
a taco Titan was actually showing up or
when there was a lot of unanswered
questions so I think this year we run
more firmer ground however there is
still unknowns there are still unknowns
and that includes one punch man season
two nothing other than it's in
production the Code Geass sequel that
they've been talking about for over a
year now nothing firm all we have is one
trailer PV um what else what only clean
what fully cool that's supposed to be
announced for this year they said season
2 will be 2018 season 3 will be 2019 but
we don't know I guess when exactly
hopefully that's still gonna happen it's
not given a slot in my book it's
unconfirmed does these things are always
pushed off like it for example at this
point steins gate 0 is getting a season
in the spring so you know I believe in
it already has it's lon Tokyo ghoul read
which Anna Mac is super excited for is
getting a sequel is a genome shokugeki
no souma is getting a sequel
Gintama is getting
I mean these are you know slated already
they have the we finally have horror
this year as well that's something we
have the best that we have the best
manga horror artists finally getting a
net like anime adaptation to his stuff
like June g8o stuff is godly and he's
finally getting ahead of a to it I hope
you're not talking about that that
torture porn thing as a bunch of
different but um yeah four fully cooled
and made an abyss season two those are
those shows that are not don't have like
wide amount of mainstream hype but I'm
definitely excited for and do we have a
slot for uh made an abyss do Knox um I
believe that it does have a slot I think
it's for next summer might actually I
don't know I don't know summer yep
summer I checked on my that's one of
those were you know I know quite a few
people appreciate it but it's not like
that it's not like one of those animes
that has fanboys and like a huge amount
of hype but I'm still looking forward to
it
Jack Cooper asked in the chat will I
make theories about the new Dragon Ball
episode I don't make episodes for
theories for each episode generally but
when I come up with like a theory or
something crosses my mind in general
then I'll make a video so if that
happens I do have some theories on the
way so videos will be coming but I don't
necessarily review every episode I think
that at this point but we'll see in the
future I don't know
what happens happens we'll have to wait
and find out well yeah so one thing that
I want to get in this stream to talk
about I personally don't know very many
new anime that are coming out this year
that are hyped like I know some of the
studio trigger stuff like what was
called the one
something Frank oh darling in the front
in the front yes yes that was looks
really interesting we've seen the
previews for it looks real interesting
um I'm excited to see that one and ahbar
not ever gonna know
oh yes an involuntary garden also again
I feel like that's one of those is gonna
be like made an abyss people are gonna
appreciate it but it's never gonna get
that mainstream kind of height but
definitely gonna check that out
however those are yet to really see
aside from like Death Note I can't
really think of any non Shonen that got
that mainstream hype I mean well ever
gotten on Netflix can we define the hype
though to be more specific on so that
cycle for not being a short did that's
true 100% you're right yes correct
Netflix claimed violet ever garden oh
god no no no someone just commented that
Netflix will be streaming it please
don't have me please no no no I don't
see anything about that someone just
commented out thank you so is getting a
second season though that's really cool
um in the series I'm looking forward to
is basilisk which is starting soon soul
are you sure you're not excited for that
pooh-poohed MPP cuisine pull over
animated anime the art style is pure
short or actually a full series the most
look it up no I want to only check out
dynasty as that's that's the Manoir
because you know the Queen's have been
coming up now in it doing their own
they're an amazing stuff like we had
that one with the game and stuff you
know PJ and things like that so there's
time to produce more now so I want to
check okay I wanna see what's going on
I've been that door I mean
oh no there's not many originals all but
in like viola ever garden I'm not wonder
that movie
I think it's movie that I showed you on
a Mac i DM do you in yeah would you call
it yeah yeah like that looks interesting
the thing is when like made an abyss
no one was hyped for making abyss before
and actually aired no one actually knew
about it no one was excited for it yeah
for as far as the original anime look
that's art look good but that was about
as much as we knew about it right yeah
and unfortunately Netflix has conquered
pilot every Gordon is that as I said
like you're not gonna stream it anyway
yeah I know what I'm saying I'm sorry
or are they going to just wait eight
months and then post it my guess we can
want to be like violet ever garden will
be on Netflix about at the same time as
Trump is going for a second term you
know fansubs they're not [ __ ] let's just
hope they're not [ __ ] by the way William
says the legend of the Galactic Heroes
remake is that can 2018 confirm yes no
actually thinking is it a remake it's
only 12 episodes no it's not it's not we
make us a retelling basically the
original series that we go isn't it
doesn't exactly follow the original
novel the D create a role where is this
new one is that scuse me I don't know I
I have mixed feelings I would like
Brotherhood dinner but Brotherhood was
good but a lot of these remakes don't
end up being or retellings none of them
being as good for example with quino's
journey I really like the original this
remake has been really hit and miss from
last season some episodes were good some
episodes were like what the [ __ ]
so yeah I don't know like I've mixed
feelings obviously I want to see a cool
legend about heroes retelling since that
anime is
from the early to mid 80s I believe so
obviously if the animation is gonna be
vastly different it's gonna be a lot
more technology they can use to make it
more epic but again story is key so can
they make a good story or are they gonna
ruin it I don't know I'll give it a shot
for sure comes out it comes out April
that's when it comes it comes April 2018
three twelve episodes
oh my god you guys in the summer there's
two it was just like we were talking
about the bestiality lolly thing and
there's literally no I'm a girl
look I'm stove is a every single one
falls into these fetish categories that
I really hate oh this one is a trap oh
this one is a powder trap oh there's a
lolly sister that's nice we don't know
when we saw the trailer for fate of paul
kappa and they showed on a stolen phone
we don't know whether he was a trap
until the series confirmed it but if the
show's called trap puddin it's not a
good sign no I think this is gonna be
the era been for horror I really think
this is the year again for Wars because
like winter fall it's that way to go
into fall I need to go in the winter
there are two good series and in spring
has a good Syria like why are you so
[ __ ] funeral and cat girls and like
what happened
traditional fetish of just girls with
huge boobs like what like can we just
can we just have some girls as we all
know they're not monsters or animals
just girls like little and in my mind
there is an anime very similar to K Joe
coming out actually it's a volleyball XE
anime with girls playing volleyball I'm
excited just because brilliance was they
made a game that could only be perfected
by its environment now there were
ping-pong and edgy anime that sucked
you know I don't know like not a little
boy I enjoy volleyball in general I
don't be volleyball 2k joy in terms of
drama and I like volleyball there's not
words so I'll give it a shot
what yeah like I don't know I I don't a
lot of these anime and that's why I
don't like certain you know pandering
style anime that just throw in like your
geek no game no lifes what's a less
throw in a furry let's go in a lolly
sister let's go in a girl that just
takes your calls up randomly and there
you have it the perfect plot Oh elf girl
elf girl in games oh yeah not just a
girl I know Mike it's the one from what
does a cold the guy was the author and
this girl always takes her clothes off
just to write you know the what it was a
cold Eromanga sense it no it's the other
one that aired last season all right I
only watch one arrow manga since a per
year that's why we're so young you're
talking about the sister what's it was
the very first episode where the where
the sister was you know yeah yeah yeah
the little sister is all you need
by the way the anime took a huge turn
and apparently after like episode three
it became really good yeah it was
actually very good but very weird at the
same time apparently many people enjoyed
it and they're talking about it you know
it needs another season because no way
it ends there yeah well a lot of people
not gonna convince me to watch it after
that first episode was good after the
first 20 episodes of but you know to
each their own
by the way cat gamer in the chat said he
got 47% on his exam because he's been
watching too many too much anime so you
got to balance your time you've got also
prioritize Anna Mac give him some
motivation alright alright
it's because he's watching the wrong
enemy [ __ ] you gotta look like ghost in
the shell and then you got an exam and
you're just like talking about a eyes
and what it means to be a person versus
a machine and the professor complain I
don't know what they're talking about
this Ripper I would just recommend him
to watch pure harem watch harem then
you're gonna get excited now you're
gonna get that 100% of your I am the
role model I am the harem King anyway um
yeah there's a few there's a few of
series honestly in the spring there's a
welter Kuniko a while muzu kashi which
is a comedy romance which is pretty good
that wasn't for my money directly by the
way I've been thank you
I've been reading the manga is a really
good show well it should be if it's done
correctly because it is done by a-1
pictures then there's like an emphasis
on all-star series coming out called
with Genesis which obviously it's an
all-star come on up then there's you
know inky Pandora which is a macro
slicers it's North Star everyone wants
more JoJo's men no no the original ox
you're the only guy on Red Cafe who
loves Gintama and you know food Wars and
Joey
young mister actually yes
second of all of the only one of the
riot Cafe de wash Gintama and jojos so
that's 100% rating for both of those
shows no watch them boys and keep going
on Oh actually I have one more thing to
say
misty here and she raided JoJo's
attendant attend his favorite anime is
freaking hunter hunter that's not really
an anime Cardcaptor Sakura actually
brain but there is an anime I'm excited
for
there's actually two anime I'm excited
for in winter and it is beatless and
citrus those two are mostly excited
citrus is URI anime and yes although it
is edgy our Bayless is not actually
harem
no killing bites at you hard killing it
might be bad I don't know I want to
watch it and that's because the
thumbnail has a cat girl congratulations
he doesn't say I like oh wow I'm so high
for it I mean it looks good but I don't
know what get up to Mike it's all about
girls you know fighting monsters and
[ __ ] in fantasy no no no that no that's
not what it's about at all wait you read
the manga NOx obese overweight it's
always good to have soul for these types
of streams because he's read like older
manga so he knows what actually we do
look forward to whereas I just like look
and a list of upcoming everything I'm
like anime and I'm like book [ __ ]
I have no idea what's happening so good
on you so good thank you thank you mean
well one thing about soul is before
anyone publishes a manga they check with
him first
yes that's right that's right I'm dead
in Jiki what so you should be an editor
I said you learn learn fluent Japanese
soul learn food company now by the way
personally another another kind of trend
that I'm seeing
sometimes it's having an anime we're
like two girls just have these like
weird borderline Yuri moe
moments randomly and then never followed
up on again it's just like blatant like
what's why are they you read like
insinuations here there was no nothing
leading up to it and then after I don't
want even notices it later it's like
just kind of like again Fanfan there
it's like oh you thought something was
gonna happen it didn't sound like anime
in a nutshell that's another trope now
on top of the you know the furries and
the other stuff that's it's will they
won't they they somehow land in bed and
then the other girl character opens the
door and it's all awkward I feel like
that's half yeah don't do any one of you
even like Yuri I do nice either although
I don't like I'm actually awake of Yuri
I'm a big phone my favorite years of all
time is actually Sakura trick if you
guys haven't watched definitely see it
good I love soccer Ettrick but what I
think it was me
looking forward to citrus I hope it's
good because the manga is super popular
so yeah like a looking forward to it as
well yes I remember watching that was it
kind of I think it's kind of zukie know
Miko and basically the Yuri in that show
ruined it like it got really weird
really quick yeah I mean like first
you've got this guy liking this girl you
can call up this mecha notice and I was
pretty cool and then like he kisses her
oh yeah you know they've become a couple
she cries he ones off then she goes to
the supper girl gets tied up mind broken
abused and then apparently those two are
in love with each other I'm an Asian man
some girls like some girls like to be
dominated okay
yeah you would fla some girls like
domination is what i'm talking about the
type of your young time i was like when
the story doesn't really call for it
it's just sort of like a fan pandering
thing where it's like it makes no sense
in the context of the characters and
what we know about them so far that's
the problem when you know when you're
throwing in tropes you know for the fans
for fanboys and instead of actually if
that's the story that's the point and
you see a from the game the story how it
happens then that makes sense but if
it's like the whole time the girl is
with like a guy and then also she's like
with like girl it's like what why yeah
necklace - okay girl if it seems like it
doesn't make sense and cutting the
context that they've established where
the characters dead to me I'm thinking
they're only doing this to get fan boys
to talk about it not because they
actually care about the characters in
the story and that's my problem
lemming sense though what about Nexus or
trap into your no no Daisy it's like
that scums wish horrible the whole new
stories like bad enemy they just
horrible stories like why would you want
to like never mind in digest not crazy I
didn't like NTR scums which was all
right oh no it wasn't no it wasn't no
that was pretty bad man I heard that was
good a lot of people liked it yeah yeah
those of you who have not watched comes
wish it's basically about how everyone's
in a relationship that they don't want
to be in yeah I've heard of it I don't
see it I love dark and like not a happy
ending stuff I like it can also be done
stupidly so I've seen both I've seen
volume like not everything has how happy
I need as long as it makes sense with
the story as long as it's actual cool
anything makes you think but you can
also do it in a way that was just like
why like the story was leading up to one
thing and then another thing happens
you're like you wasted my [ __ ] time
and that's the biggest thing with iron
blooded orphans was the ending was
completely an [ __ ] completely made no
sense and I was just like please yeah I
mean that's what that's once Tom's wish
is like though there's no point to the
story right some people might like that
like you know the dark or gritty kind of
feel that you know okay no all
relationships are perfect cool but tell
me what was the point in that story that
was a point that was a boy no no you
just said the point comes one talking
about before is like like with Cowboy
Bebop we were talking about this before
like the title is what it is it's us
comes wish the story is prevalent around
these characters who cannot be happy and
that's the meaning of the story doesn't
have to have ending that makes you feel
conclusive or a cliffhanger or what
you're used to
you know the story in the end of the
story is the same so there's no
progression within that story you start
here you end there and you'll that
wasn't the intent was to make you feel
like [ __ ] and realize that there is like
a [ __ ] ton of people are with people
that they're not happy with I would say
that felt then because I yes yeah that's
the best point it's supposed to make you
like you know feel all the negative
feelings rather than feel that there's a
progression of the story it wasn't you
know what I mean like it's it's hard to
say it's hard to play it should come
with a trigger warning basically yeah if
I want to see people being Miss
like that's not what I won't look for an
anime like you know look the the anime
order wish gums wish wasn't really a bad
show for most of it until you realize
that it's all getting screwed up because
the teacher is a [ __ ] like Kathy just
because the teacher knocks I mean
there's others so there's other part of
what happened even in the series caster
for life says then I Animax should be
the main character and scums wish I have
no idea whether that's a condolence or
not because I don't know I haven't seen
it you don't be anyone in that no one
trusts me adamak there's a lot of
cheating in that series so I mean that
was one sweet girl the the guy light or
what the girl liked him and I thought
okay there might be some kind of
salvation did you see someone might be
saved no there's a girl likes this guy
and then she likes this other guy and
then she likes the girl or she goes back
to the guy go back to the girl [ __ ] like
that
and then she sees another girl well the
guy there's there's a bunch of [ __ ]
misunderstandings and cheating in that
series yeah I hate that I hate in shows
where it's all about misunderstanding
and people being too too much of a [ __ ]
to actually like what was worse was when
the teacher like basically she's ready
cheated by sleeping with a student just
because he showed her attention that's
how reasoning okay
not a bad reason I know but you know I
mean like what know what was worse is
her fiance who is another teacher she
she just ends up turning on when it gets
exposed on the street on the high street
she just turns on to the guy and she's
like yeah that's me
that's what I do someone showed me
attention I'm gonna sleep with them I'm
always gonna cheat on you you have to
accept that and the guy just goes yeah I
accept that I still I still love you all
where's the backbone man there's some
guys out there though that don't have
backbones like that now we got problems
in the series that ruined it a little
bit no I'm just saying that there are
actually people out there like dominates
them remember how she said that some
women like dominating yeah yeah whoa
whoa no idea today yeah
seek out an attainment through Batman
not who the guy who drives the bus every
day yeah no people not [ __ ] if he
wants to see people being miserable
he'll go to the library during finals
week agree with this man if you see
students study and finally they're like
pajamas they've got like there's a mess
they look like they just got like like
got out of like a haunted house where
they were being forced to watch tokyo
ghoul 24/7 for three days like it's
crazy it's crazy I was gonna say maka
watching one piece in one sitting but
okay yeah maka watching JoJo's yeah I
feel like the soul if he probably gives
giorgos more of a chance they'll
probably end up enjoying it but no no no
no there's too many normal people
enjoying it that I respect for me to see
it is that bad it's just yeah it's just
weed is weed is to like you bizarre
listen to soul nobody feels like he
doesn't know what it wants to me like
you can't watch it and gay it's like it
does
no reasoning for plot because it's just
full of plot holes anyway so the plot
doesn't matter it's just [ __ ] happening
just like [ __ ] happening and that's it
I'm not gonna fight with you because you
haven't watched it you know yeah I've
watched enough for what time whatever
you say man I'd rather move on also a
few people are mentioning a few people
have mentioned a time and time to season
three and my hero academia Suzuki
obviously huge hype for those like I
feel like we don't even need to talk
about those now much because we talked
about it already so much seasons will be
amazing if you look at my hair give me a
season three in the manga what happens
it's gonna be [ __ ] amazing if you
look at a target like the same thing in
the manga season three is gonna be crazy
so many twists learning so many new
things just blowing your mind it's gonna
be not so both of those are gonna be
great I can't wait if we've got any
Roman spans or Roman scum defense then
for romance on the top of generally
called Corey hua Mei gari no unique
which is my little girl my daughter
Roman scum there's a tarik i josu you
know takagi son which starts on the 8th
of January so yeah those are two series
that start this movement if you're into
it check it out yeah yeah I think I'm
looking forward to sort out online
alternative done Yale yeah no guys
actually I was reading that that was
that that's such an interesting comment
that bad than the main series
allocations books all mostly for the
third season the issue with the third
season it's not even canon the third
season is all filler she's such a good
baby I'm sorry she's so good
all right guys we're changing to talk to
this dream so sorry no I was just like
so touched that she wanted to say good
and contributors for the stream she's
here in the back you don't need to
support me I was gonna say that do we
know when we're gonna actually don't
forget the sods my here academia and at
our thing are gonna get most likely I
know no I don't I don't think twelve
would cover for like as as you know Anna
Mack Pokemon hero I don't think twelve
episodes are gonna cover I think you
don't need more what cause no doubt it's
gonna be those two I'd guess that
classes to arts but they're very closely
linked so they'll probably be done
together in one season like how in the
last season we got the whole disdain
well games the same and then the
graduation you know all together so yeah
I feel like with my hair up being a
definitely need 25 and with the doctor
paint I would love to see 25 but we
don't know because attack McCain has
been so flaky but like I don't know if
there's any way to know or at what point
we're gonna know how many we're actually
gonna get for sure so that we don't have
to be you know speculating as for the
sequels we know that over the words of
season two aired yesterday how did you
guys find it I haven't seen it yet or
they're gonna include the following arc
in the season one or two I liked it I
was really happy
to see inés an albedo again season two's
good it's okay but season three is
giving a season three already how old do
you realize that if your kid was ten
years older she would be a Logan fan
part my son my son downstairs he's 11
and he's not a Logan frontage difference
between parents they actually watch
their kids vs. parents like don't give a
[ __ ] with their kids like sat down and
watch the Ghibli movie when what morning
was that huh start you know stuffing
them with some one piece man no yeah so
start the meds I love my I love my kids
Pokemon the very first Pokemon season
one thank you yes Pokemon my boy
Gilgamesh says that this year is the
year of bleach bleach but at least knock
star who paid homage to bleach in his
board jawbridge so there's that there's
that Shaymin was it shaming king is that
the enemy does a good one that was a
good one I let my kid sit down
definitely Shura says Marni is on the
radio I never heard anyone say anything
bad about it no no but it doesn't get
enough
like coverage as it should because it is
really good many ways they good my
favorite my favorite thunder hands down
is my favorite and it still makes me
tear up
it's like yes what does a lot of bro a
lot of stuff when money was there that
is just yeah trust me well who the [ __ ]
is Miyazaki that's my meme of 2017 you
need to make me for 2018 now well I'm
sure you'll say something years on his
died but I really like the cat where was
the cow from again though there's no key
the documentary it's about his life and
since the movie is called the Cat
Returns yes all of his movies are good
yeah that was all right that was
interesting but a big incestuous kind of
okay was really good when I watch
something my brain just blocks it out I
don't know if that's my studio I don't
know it's letters to Momo oh that is
good yeah that is a good one no it was
there all those fairy tale Sao you know
Tokyo ghoul some people like that stuff
so we have to include it
anything really or a full time for
little panic I am opening there's I
think there's funny as well
Fafnir I think there's a new factory
coming in so this you don't know about
that
there is insane alive everyone loves day
alive come on now thing you know the
Train thing attack on titan on a train
with zombies
oh yeah justice season to suppose we
come in and same like the magical index
as well hospitals drift about collect
yes the first season was pretty bold yes
mum for still 2018 but they alive still
has a date to be announced so just as
likely 2018 there is we make fun of
muscle Gatto in hxh season too
Bahamut my now we're friends that
supposed to be coming in so accentuate
my point
take century my point Minh Aria friends
will God an airdate in 2016 and 2017
okay
and it was pushed off till here so again
get a month I'm not buying it yes does a
new ghost in the show in the works but
there's no date or anything but we do
know production i.g
yes a lot of people ask me any news
about till we get a month I don't buy
any of it because so far like do give us
something an animatic I've found a
series for you it's done by gonzo and
it's coming out 2018 is comedy sci-fi
signing slice of life and the series is
good which sank and tara misu yeah yeah
yeah come these sci-fi sign in
slice-of-life I don't know yeah
there is the show I'm excited for coming
out in six days it's called Death March
Takara hajimaru is a kind it's another
it's a guy series and it pretty much
reminds me of Ishikawa smartphone
hopefully fingers crossed not it's about
this guy who apparently gets transported
to another world is superwoman and yes
no I'm serious and he has super amazing
powers and he just hides it from his
peers yes our boys a godly world where
he has magical power can I tell you
diction one you want to go kill the king
that will be his prediction - is it will
make no difference to the actual story
that it was an East guy and he was a
thirty year old guy that's now a 15 year
old guy play no role in the story
whatsoever fool to relate to this maybe
29 year old loser
maybe you'll get transported to another
world to kill a demon king I don't know
I mean he it says in the description
that he wipes out an entire army of
lizards because he's so [ __ ]
overpowered and then for the for the
rest of the series he just hides his
true power bunch of girls and then
builds his houses
sorry he's low tear compared to overload
whatever look like one of ours our goals
minions can do that stuff so don't worry
I don't know I just found it buddy and
the demon king in the description
no way story such as return of the demon
king oh yeah and that's why that's why
it is like started clamping down on
these great stories for competitions
they're like you're not allowed to write
no more no more just accepting them
anymore because they always that all the
same crap like it's like with Twilight
coming out started coming out about
[ __ ] vampires for like five years
vampires for everyone I think you know
what's gonna be a rare find an actual
harem anime adult women I know it's also
gets that lovely lolly and then we have
the maid trope and then we have the
massive boobs tropes and
all the girls on Marietta is like the
best law no no no no actually we doing
about old one we have the guy with all
these monster wives
cashy you're looking forward to now I
gotta Oh guess what it's about girls
that get turned on by lollipops
I can she movie all series they came out
more yeah that's when it gets the crap
and he's done a teacher yeah nobody
here's a Molly fan anyway guys in terms
of this I think overall it's gonna be a
really really interesting year because
we have some crazy big sequels coming
out and while we have some new anime
coming out to look very like ISA Kai and
stupid and you know you know cliche we
could still be surprised by some really
cool anime we know that some interesting
new anime is coming we could still be
surprised by some quality and as long as
you know the my ear academia and attack
on science live up to the hype and stay
true to their manga which is very
interesting a good years my take away
kind of like expect to get some hype for
some hope to be positively surprised by
some new stuff so that's kind of my main
house going into it we can start our
sign off now but if you wanna uh another
exciting we go from one person to the
other knocks let me know when you're
looking forward to the most this coming
year and also who you are what you do
and I'm port or bridge I'm next a coup I
do anime content you know you won't
believe me unless you check
so do that we also this is the first
stream that we had a lolly on stream it
was the perfect time for his headphones
to fall off I have to say and also what
I'm excited for that we didn't really
talk about since no one watched of
course the psyche Cousteau no sorry man
second season okay thank you Knox
Thank You Knox for for your feedback
recon to you three in highschool DxD her
life [ __ ] [ __ ] except they both
don't have dates this year I know what
they're hopefully gonna come 2018
anyways so hopefully I'm hoping here
Jojo part five and Maggie season three
put that movie you never know anyways
what's up bebop see the two [ __ ] what
it's your boy recon and I do them anime
top ten lists and yeah that's about it
gogo and I check me out if you want
recommendations because I do recommend
anime and apparently everyone says I
have [ __ ] taste Thank You Noah got oh we
do Anime News and soon we're gonna be
jumping into animations and also games
as well and I'm mostly excited for Jun
Jie eatos collection and we didn't talk
about this but I'm very excited for
right through animation and yeah looking
forward to seeing animations on your
channel now I'll be sure to keep us
posted
I will I just take in forever make you
yeah I mean cover manga manga is the
best you know is the source the Canon
I have food videos lined up first one's
gonna be freezing magnet and make
comparison then there's going to be the
under 100 chapter top 10 you should lead
mangas and then after that it's going to
be the Rosario vampire manga anime
comparison first video which is the
freezing video should drop on Monday and
yeah that's me
nice thank you so looking forward to
that obviously everyone's channel is in
the description and yeah this was a fun
chat we will do once in a few weeks once
this winter 2018 season gets going we
will do a first impressions stream as
well almost like we're talking about
what we like so far or what you might be
missing do you want to check out why you
should stay away from usually the stuff
recon recommends yeah yeah and that kind
of stuff just looking on the whole
someone has come on that we sense it's
coming in two days in two days is the
first time sort on Saturday so that's
gonna be crazy
that's gonna be crazy I'm looking
forward to that as well and until next
time see ya space cowboy
wait wait guys I'm ejecting recon from
the stream no no get him there he is
he's got it